كل المؤشرات في اوكرانيا لا تنظر سباب
التصعيد فمساله ارسال الاسلحه الغربيه
لكيف تثير مزيدا من التعقيد في الحرب
وتقلق روسيا كثيرا فبعد الجدل حول
الدبابات اعلنت واشنطن تزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه بعيده المدى لاول مره منذ بدء
الحرب مسؤول امريكيون افادوا بان واشنطن
تعد حزمه مساعده عسكريه بقيمه 2.2 مليار
دولار ومن المتوقع ان تشمل سلاحا بعيدا
المدى كمعداد دعم لانظمه الدفاع الجويو
وذخائر دقيقه التوجيه والصواريخ جابر
متوسطه
للدبابات بحسب ما اكل المسؤولون
في اوكرانيا يرتفع سقف المساعدات العسكريه
لاول مره حزمه مساعدات الامريكيه جديده
لاوكرانيا
صواريخ طويله المدى
المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه الاوكرانيا
تشمل معدات دعم لانظمه الدفاع الجوي
[موسيقى]
المضاده للدبابات
خائره دقيقه
[موسيقى]
من المتوقع ان تشمل المساعدات ايضا
المركبات المقاومه للالغام وانظمه اطلاق
الصواريخ المتعدده الموجهه والذخيره
تبلغ قيمه تلك المساعدات مليارين ومئتين
مليون دولار
وهذه الحزمه الامريكيه اقلقت روسيا التي
حذرت على لسان المتحدث
واكد ان الصواريخ الاطول المدى ستفاقم
الصراع وان الرئيس
محادثات مع نظيره الامريكي
همم حتى الان لا توجد خطط لاجراء محادثات
بين بوتين هدفنا الرئيسي الان هو مواصله
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه ونهدف ايضا الى
تنفيذ المهام المحدده هناك مستجدات في
الوقت الحاضر نرى ان البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه للناتو تعملو ضد الاتحاد الروسي
كما ان البنيه التحتيه الاستطلاعيه للناس
باكملها في ذلك الطائرات والاقمار
الصناعيه تعمل على مدار الساعه طوال ايام
الاسبوع لصالح اوكرانيا بالطبع كل هذا
يخلق ظروفا عاديا لا يسعنا الا ان ناخذها
في الاعتبار